when we arrived at the destination we
would hasten to a hotel to unpack
and immediately set out on a tour of
observation
we spent days on trains with screaming
wheels and screeching whistles
careering through billowing clouds of
smoke amid belching flames
and the smell of iron soot and smoke
caked our bodies and flew into our eyes
when darkness fell and we had reached
our hotel rooms we scarcely had time to
wipe off the dirt
before it was time for the next banquet
we wore out
our eyes and our ears at theaters no
sooner did we go to bed at night
then it was time to wake up with
representatives from the next factory
awaiting us
as a result many marvellous sights and
unfamiliar sounds filled our days
day by day however our bodies and nerves
grew exhausted
and we became weary of splendid dinners
we wished
just once to enjoy the simple pleasures
of drinking plain water
and lying with our heads pillowed on our
bent elbows
but to do so would have damaged our
relations with these other countries
as i edit these volumes i recall the
wonderful sights and sounds we saw and
heard
on our travels to some of the most
distant parts of the earth
with the passage of time those memories
now seem like images of splendid
mountains engraved in my heart
our travels are already fading into a
fleeting dream
and our hardships are like wounds which
have already healed
my thoughts and feelings at this time
may only be appreciated by those who
have experienced
a similar lengthy journey
our ship was called the america reputed
to be the most elegant vessel in the
pacific male steamship company fleet
the america was 363 feet long 57 feet
wide
and 23 feet deep we moved out of
yokohama bay
and sailed along the boso peninsula and
through the waters off sagami and izu
we could see snow on the slopes of mount
fuji
glittering in the evening sun the
scenery was magnificent
and we all looked back nostalgically
feeling sad
to be leaving the landscape of japan
[Music]
behind
at first light this morning the sea fog
was so thick that we could not
distinguish objects which were only a
foot away from us
as the sun rose and the mists began to
lift we could distinguish the mountains
of california ahead our ship advanced
slowly
directly to the east two mountain ridges
parted to reveal a great
natural gateway this was the celebrated
golden gate in our 22-day voyage across
the pacific ocean
this was the first land we had glimpsed
east of japan
words are inadequate to express our
pleasure as we gazed upon this golden
gateway
where sea and sky meet directly to the
west
and coastal mountains rise on both sides
[Music]
this video was sponsored by magellan tv
the documentary streaming service
so coco is quite insistent everybody
signs up for magellan tv
and she wants everybody to do it through
her new bitcoin service
coco coin she's been tweeting a deal on
musk all day
and so to tempt you in me and coco have
a recommendation
ellis island a history of the american
dream
as always magellan tv offers a great
parallel to our videos
and this is just one of more than 3 000
documentaries available
and you can now take advantage of an
exclusive offer 30
off an annual membership this gives you
an entire year for less than 3.50 a
month
even if you've joined magellan before
and lapsed
you can simply click on the link in the
description to claim your discounted
membership today
thanks
in no time we had disembarked climbed
into horse-drawn carriages and been
conveyed to the grand hotel
on montgomery street where we arrived at
11 o'clock
lace curtains on the windows give the
impression of looking at flowers through
a mist
the smaller rooms are about the size of
an eight tatami mat room in japan
the beds have mattresses with metal
springs underneath but the mattresses
are soft and the springs do not touch
the body directly
there are wardrobes and chests of
drawers in which to place one's clothes
and a basin where one can wash one's
face
when one turns on the faucet clean water
comes gushing out
since most western hotels have similar
facilities it will not be necessary to
describe them all in such detail
readers may imagine what the others are
like
customs and character in the east and
west are very different indeed at times
they seem to be direct
opposites westerners enjoy social
activities and public events
eastern peoples tend to avoid them this
is not only a relic of japan's policy of
national isolation
eastern peoples are also indifferent to
wealth and do not regard commerce as a
primary concern
westerners like to go out and enjoy
themselves socially
and even in the smallest towns they
establish public gardens
eastern people on the other hand prefer
to stay indoors to relax
creating gardens within their own houses
from utah territory in the west through
wyoming lies the largest stretch of
wilderness in the united states
even with the train racing at full speed
we did not reach a major population
center until we had traveled for a full
four days
withered prairie grass and thick scrubs
stretched away endlessly
here and there we saw native indians or
their pit dwellings
only every 10 miles or so did we see
small hamlets consisting of two or three
houses beside the track
beyond the railway rugged peaks
continued for a thousand miles
there was not the shadow of a single
bird although one may
tire hearing about the vastness of the
united states
when one experiences it it is even more
astonishing than one could believe
the current population of the united
states is much the same as that of japan
however in size the united states is
dozens of times larger
it is truly astonishing how much of this
land is under cultivation
it made japanese farmers seem indolent
by comparison
when we arrived at the arlington hotel
we learned that mrs grant
the wife of the president had sent a
magnificent bouquet of fresh flowers for
ambassador iwakura
the bouquet was reported to have cost
300
such a gift represents great tribute in
the west
at noon we were granted the honor of a
formal state reception
at which we presented our credentials to
president grant
the president's official residence is
located very close to arlington hotel
merely one square away to the west
it is known as the white house
and presidents live here from the day of
their inauguration until the end of
their term of office
the laws of the united states are very
relaxed especially so in washington
even foreign visitors are permitted easy
access to the white house
and allowed to go sightseeing freely
unhindered by guards
americans smile rather scornfully about
european palaces
and other sites where soldiers guard the
premises and forbid entry to the common
people
they think this is a very antiquated
undemocratic custom
we visited a college for black students
the recent conflict between the north
and the south
erupted during the debate over the
emancipation of black people
from their manacles of slavery which
flared into a great war
blood flowed for four years until
eventually the issue was settled
and for the first time black people
gained the freedom enjoyed by other
americans
however because they had been made to
labor like horses and oxen
they were regarded as ignorant and
uncultured
even today there is still a tendency for
white people to feel
shame about associating with them for
this reason public schools have been
established so that black children can
receive the same education
as white children even though their
schools are separate
slaves were emancipated and for the
first time were recognized as human
beings
this however did not bring greater
contact between the races
the separation between white and black
people is as distinct as that between
clear and muddy water some black people
achieved freedom early on
other outstanding black people were
elected to the house of representatives
and still
others have accumulated great wealth
clearly the colour of one's skin has
nothing to do with intelligence
people with insight have recognized that
education is the key to improvement
it is not inconceivable that within a
decade or two
talented black people will rise and
white people
who do not study and work hard will fall
by the wayside
at eleven o'clock in the morning
escorted by general myers
we visited the united states post office
[Music]
we were next shown the sorting and
delivery department where postal workers
sought all the letters posted in the
city's mailboxes
when one buys anything in a european or
american city
as soon as the price is settled the
clerk requests the address where the
items to be delivered
when we asked clerks to have the parcels
sent to japan
they always complied we send details of
the purchase by mail or telegram
to inform people in japan about the
shipment even though it may take a
number of days
the items will be delivered to one's
home
when japanese people think of the west
they imagine
some distant galaxy when western
merchants view the world however
they see it as a single city with this
attitude
they cannot fail to prosper
from the earliest days of intercourse
between the east and the west
the two have not really understood each
other since they have totally different
outlooks
with the customs and character of the
one the opposite of those of the other
in every respect down to the smallest
detail
since our embassy embarked on the
american ship in yokohama
we have been journeying through a realm
of foreign customs
and just as our behavior is surprising
to the americans
their customs seem baffling to us
among these differing customs by far the
strangest was the social relations
between men and women
in conjugal and family relations in
japan a wife is dutiful to her mother
and father-in-law
and children show respect to their
parents
in america however it is the custom for
the husband to serve his wife
this may involve carrying her lantern or
shoes offering her delicacies dusting
off her garments
helping her when she boards her lights
from a carriage pushing her chair
forward when she sits
or carrying articles for her when she is
walking
if the husband senses even the slightest
displeasure from his wife he
demonstrates his love and respect by
bowing
and apologizing if the apology is not
accepted
he may be sent out of the room and
cannot even eat when men and women are
traveling in the same carriage
the men stand immediately to offer their
seats to the women
who take them without hesitation while
women are present
men are circumspect in their behavior
speaking softly and avoiding cursing an
argument
if these rules of behaviour were to be
transplanted and replace our forms of
filial duty towards our parents
that would represent a great improvement
[Music]
broadway is the busiest street in new
york city
overflowing with carriages horses and
people on the cobblestone surface
this is the most crowded street in the
world
in our hotel rooms overlooking broadway
the din was at times so loud
as a hundred thunderclaps or a gale
blowing at full force through a forest
of pine trees
[Music]
accompanied by guides provided by the
new york city government
we visited the astor library from there
we went to the bible society
this society was established with
donations collected from those who
wanted to spread the bible's teachings
throughout the world
at that time the book had already been
translated into 30 languages
not only does everyone in america own a
copy of the bible which is kept in each
home
but if people go away on a journey of a
few weeks they feel obliged
to take it with them it is especially
revered by
women if the owner is wealthy the book
may be lavishly bound and decorated with
golden jewels
and some spare no expense in adorning
their bible
the bible is the sacred book of the west
and the basis of the people's morality
it is veneration of god which drives
people to work hard
good behavior is the basic element in
maintaining order in society
and gives rise to the enrichment and
strengthening of a country
it is like oxygen
thus when western people talk about a
nation and its character
they always discuss religion when a
foreigner comes to their country
they always ask what religion he
observes and what god he worships
when they meet someone who professes no
faith they think of him as a lost
soul or a heathen from the wilderness
they become wary of him
and sever all social relations
they tend to think that a person who
does not have a religion
will not respect the law
when we read the old and new testaments
which christians respect
some parts contain unbelievable tales
of voices from heaven or relate the
resurrection of a crucified criminal
thus the bible can easily be dismissed
as the ramblings of a lunatic
we were suspicious of the tears of those
who prayed before a man condemned to
death for heresy
whom they acclaim as the son of a
celestial king
every city in the west has images of
this dead man being taken down from a
cross
with streaks of blood running down his
body these images are hung on the walls
and placed in the corners of rooms
giving the impression that one is
passing through a cemetery
or lodging at a place of execution is
this not a strange custom
yet westerners think it's strange that
people in the east have not accepted
christianity
and even rational people well-versed in
world affairs
urged us to display these images
what is their intention western people
are sincere in worshiping god and
practicing morality
they are hard working and strive to
cooperate with one another
the root of this cooperation is to be
found in religion
so it cannot be explained simply in
terms of form
and theory we must inquire about the
actual
practice of it in the east confucianism
is a system of ethical principles
and buddhism is is a religion these two
teachings provide the essential
guidelines for governing a nation
and have permeated the hearts of the
people there when it comes to beliefs
and practices
who can say which is deeper christianity
or the doctrines of the east there are
many strange aspects in christ's
teachings
and it would scarcely need an
intelligence scholar to defeat the
arguments advanced by christians
and render them silent however when we
compare the sincerity of their practice
to ours
we cannot but feel ashamed
american people treat foreigners like
family or friends
and are very warm and welcoming for five
days since our arrival in boston
especially
not only the city itself but also the
surrounding towns had been extremely
generous in entertaining us
at the time of our departure their
representatives came to the mouth of the
bay to give us a farewell feast and see
us off
this was sufficient to allow people like
us from eastern countries to reflect on
our own past
making us uncomfortable and embarrassed
at this time of enlightenment waking up
from the dream of isolation and bathing
in the harmony of worldwide relations
all the people in japan cannot fail to
engrave this
on their hearts from our arrival in san
francisco until our departure from
boston
we traversed the breadth of america and
i would like to summarize what we
witnessed
this whole country has adopted european
culture
but is filled with its own spirit of
independence
funds for promoting industry have
flooded into the land
and have multiplied greatly although
america is comparable to the whole of
europe in size
much of europe is cold and barren and
the regions flourishing there represent
only one-third the extent of those
prospering in america
kings aristocrats wealthy merchants and
large companies have monopolized
europe's land and assets
and have shaped the countries to their
own purposes there was little left for
latecomers to develop independently
such people opened up and pioneered this
land of freedom and have nurtured their
spirit of enterprise
here although they say that this country
has relied on new creativity
new development and new immigrants in
reality america is a land of people who
in europe felt the urge for independence
and self-government
most strongly america is the country
where such people have gathered
and where they are now the leaders
the land is huge and rich and because
manufactured goods and agricultural
produce are abundant
a tolerant country with a thriving
economy has been established
though many aspects are still rough hewn
all their efforts have been successful
it must be said
that this is what makes america truly
america
[Music]
you